this is Wednesday November 9th 2016 and
this is the closer I'd like to begin by
congratulating the FBI on its successful
coup against the electoral process of
the United States of America you've been
working on one of these for a while boys
and I know everybody at the bureau is
just delighted that the eff can now also
stand for fascist also let us
acknowledge a little bit more seriously
something a little larger and a little
less removed from treasonous malfeasance
the terrorists have won this after all
was their goal 15 long sad years ago to
strip from the world's foremost power
its traditions of relative and growing
tolerance to hamstrung the international
influence of a country that rarely stuck
to the double white line of the moral
Road but came closer than any other to
take our energies from trying more or
less to help the world move forward and
it said to make us direct those energies
inwards at one another within our own
borders to divide us so to complete the
rupture of our settled bizarre culture
that had been so long based on the inner
monologue of I really can't stand those
people in the other party or the other
state or the other color but my
strongest emotion is going to remain
annoyance rather than hate because we're
all Americans and we're all in this
together today officially that's gone
obviously the perpetrators of 9/11 had
other designs that have yet to come to
pass the destabilization of all the
secular states the Middle East the
rising up of the caliphate etc but for
the moment that's not important to our
discussions here because the premise of
the 2001 terrorism here was to take
those divisions that were already then
kind of apparent in American society and
multiply them by fear fear of more
attacks of sedition of disloyalty of
weakness of difference of immigrants of
minorities of the loss of the playing
field that was still tilted towards
white people but was leveling just a
little bit more every year took a long
time a long time for hatred and fear to
find some figure in this country who
would pander
to them someone whose ego and lust for
power would be the perfect vessel to
exploit our collective post-traumatic
stress disorder someone who would say
anything do anything have an answer for
everything even if the answer was made
up out of whole cloth and on the spot
the goals of those who attacked us in
2001 finally found an outlet and last
night Americans certainly half of them
with no more sense of the permanence or
importance of their decision than they
brought to their votes for American Idol
opened the door and put the spokesman
for hate and fear and bluster and most
of all incompetence in charge of the
nation collectively we have slit our own
throats and ordered mixed drank and paid
the bill $12 a glass for our own poison
there is an irony that might be noticed
in our upcoming months and years of
freefall namely that the first victims
of this act of mass madness will be many
of those who pushed the hardest for it
and put the most faith in it the
economic impacts will be felt long
before the inauguration next January
held long before Thanksgiving and the
Rust Belt states that turned against
democracy and diversity yesterday will
doubtless be the first to be consumed by
job loss and financial panic and
privation cold comfort for the rest of
us indeed so what is next well if you
look for transformation within the new
elected leader fat chance
nothing has changed him in 70 years and
if there is anything to guarantee that
he will not temper his Hitlerian
personality that he will not be
restrained by any remaining adults among
Republican leadership in the house or
the Senate that he will not reach out to
those who did not vote for him if
anything could actually increase his
obstinance and refusal to share or
delegate or think it would be this
extraordinary unprecedented development
in American history right now he thinks
he is Superman but of course he is not
Superman the economy will be a complete
shambles by the time the oath is
administered and there will be no quick
fix available for making great deals
corner cutting or bellowing I'm not
paying for sloppy work he of course will
insist that everything is great and his
me
presence will assure we have made
America great and anybody who thinks
otherwise is disloyal or an Isis
sympathizer or somebody's going to sue
and as the standard of living plummets
he will try a diversion of some kind
whoa
or the deportations maybe but boy those
things take time so he'll probably do
what they all do when there is no fix to
the vital day-to-day issues and problems
a war or some bizarre gambit in the
Middle East that will in fact restore
Isis and destabilize the world just a
little bit more every damn week it will
be bad it will be very bad Americans and
others will now die but necessarily
there will be blowback there always is
blowback against the good as the
selection just showed but also blowback
against the bad that at some juncture
soon there will be the resistance those
of us who warned against and pleaded
against and fought against this madness
will find avenues for dissent which will
have enough support in at least to
impede this monster put any title you
like in front of his name and this is
still an aggressively self-destructive
man and it will be the goal of the
resistance to help him in that task that
some other juncture soon or late
probably even before the midterms of
2018 a tipping point will be reached
whether it's war or the economy or some
wildcard we can't see yet that is
bouncing around in that great stash of
funhouse mirrors in his head it will be
the Republican governors and the
Republican senators and the Republican
congressman who will see the crowds of
Republican voters demanding action
against the irresponsible and delusional
Republican president and an impeachment
will begin of what is nominally a
Republican president by what is actually
a Republican Congress none of that is
guaranteed but it should be noted that
Richard Nixon was not forced from office
until his Republican colleagues acted in
concert with Democrats to demand his
resignation
moreover the political history of this
country for the last 50 years has been a
series of wild pendulum swings from the
Civil Rights Acts to Richard Nixon in
three years from Bill Clinton to George
W Bush in three seconds from
Barack Obama to this creature in less
than three months and if this creature
is still in charge of this government
and has not yet fled the country then
there are those midterms in 2018 on the
attempt to begin a restoration unless he
acts in the interim against free
elections and I would never assume that
in a nightmare like this the Freddy
Krueger in chief suddenly starts obeying
the laws in any event I want to leave
you with two quotes
it's HL Mencken from 1926 and the long
form of it actually is no one in this
world so far as I know has ever lost
money by under estimating the
intelligence of the great masses of the
plain people and the other of course is
you can fool all the people some of the
time and some of the people all the time
but you cannot fool all the people all
the time that is attributed to Abraham
Lincoln and it pretty much sums up that
phase of the American experiment which
the electorate decided to end last night
because there is of course no real
evidence that Lincoln ever said this in
short you can fool all the people just
long enough to become the first
anti-democracy president of the United
States that's the wait one more thing
it's a conceit probably it's whistling
past graveyards perhaps a little
Churchill adjusted to the occasion
even though large tracts of America and
many old and famous states have fallen
or may fall into the grip of Trump and
all the odious apparatus of Trump rule
we shall not flag or fail we shall go on
to the end we shall fight in the state
legislatures we shall fight in the
stores and banks we shall fight with
growing confidence and growing strength
in the air we shall defend our America
whatever the cost may be we shall fight
online we shall fight in the press and
on the television we shall fight on the
street corners of public opinion we
shall never surrender
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch your back
you